aquí nos preguntan para qué valor debe y
observa que esta misma d se encuentra
aquí en esta ecuación radical se cumple
que x igual a menos 3 es una solución
extraña de la ecuación radical que
tenemos aquí y te invito a que pausa el
vídeo e intente resolver esta pregunta
por tu cuenta antes de que lo hagamos
juntos
ahora hagámoslo juntos entonces lo
primero que quiero hacer es recordar que
es una solución extraña y bueno una
solución extraña es una solución que
creemos haber obtenido pero realmente es
un subproducto que surgió de cómo
resolvimos la ecuación pero ojo no será
una solución real de nuestra ecuación
original y bueno seguramente te
preguntas cómo aparecen estas soluciones
extrañas y la respuesta es que aparecen
cuando elevas ambos lados de una
ecuación al cuadrado entonces para este
paciente aquí vamos a elevar al cuadrado
y si elevamos al cuadrado que vamos a
obtener bueno en el lado izquierdo vamos
a obtener 3x más 25 eliminamos esta raíz
cuadrada de aquí y en el lado derecho
que me va a quedar me va a quedar de
cuadrada de cuadrada
+ 2x x 2 es 4x por d 4d x + 2 x al
cuadrado es 4x cuadrada estás de acuerdo
ahora bien debes de tener cuidado porque
aquí el debe ambos lados al cuadrado
pero notan que de hecho puedes tener una
ecuación diferente la cual elevando al
cuadrado obtengas esta misma ecuación de
color amarillo y si te preguntas qué
ecuación diferente me puede dar esta
ecuación de amarillo cuando la eleva al
cuadrado bueno pues puede ser cualquier
ecuación que tenga un signo negativo en
uno de los lados de esta ecuación
original por ejemplo si tuviéramos menos
la raíz cuadrada de 3
+ 25 y bueno esto igual a de más 2x y
esto lo elevamos al cuadrado vamos a
obtener de nuevo esta ecuación de
amarillo ya que al elevar al cuadrado
algo negativo vas a obtener de nuevo
algo positivo entonces ambas ecuaciones
nuestra ecuación original y esta
ecuación diferente al elevar las al
cuadrado obtienes la misma ecuación de
amarillo al elevar al cuadrado esta de
aquí también obtienes la ecuación de
amarillo entonces cuando resuelves esta
ecuación de amarillo la cual es una
ecuación cuadrática y bueno puedes
resolver la usando la fórmula general
para las ecuaciones cuadráticas entonces
cuando la resuelves vas a obtener dos
soluciones y resulta que una de esas
soluciones será para la ecuación que
tenemos aquí de color rosa y otra de
esas soluciones va a ser la solución de
nuestra ecuación original
la solución de esta ecuación de color
rosa que tenemos aquí será una solución
extraña para nuestra ecuación original
ya que va a aparecer que es nuestra
solución pero realmente no será la
solución de la ecuación con la que
empezamos entonces cuando ellos te dicen
para que el valor de d se cumple que x
igual a menos 3 es una solución extraña
de la ecuación que tenemos aquí es
exactamente lo mismo que decir para qué
valor de d se cumple que x igual a menos
3 es una solución de la ecuación de rosa
que tenemos aquí dicho otra manera
estamos buscando una solución una
solución de esta ecuación de rosa que
tenemos aquí de esta de aquí ya que si
es solución de ésta entonces será una
solución extraña de nuestra ecuación
original observa
dos ecuaciones distintas aquí en esta
ecuación de rosa
estamos tomando el valor negativo de uno
de los dos lados y bueno si tomáramos el
valor negativo de ambos lados 10 que
recuerdan si multiplicamos por un valor
negativo de ambos lados volveríamos a
esta ecuación de aquí así que solamente
sirve que busquemos una solución de una
ecuación que hayamos multiplicado por un
signo negativo solo un lado de esta
ecuación bueno pero de cualquier manera
pensemos que el valor de de hace que x
igual a menos 3 sean una solución de
esta ecuación de color rosa y para eso
qué te parece si sustituimos el valor de
x igual a menos 3 y así obtendremos a d
entonces vamos a sustituir este valor en
esta ecuación de color rosa y que me
quedaría bueno pues me va a quedar que
menos la raíz cuadrada
de 3 x menos tres es menos nueve menos
nueve más 25 esto va a ser igual
aden adde más 2 veces x pero x vale
menos 3
entonces me va a quedar menos 6 menos 6
y bueno si de aquí resolvemos esta raíz
cuadrada voy a obtener menos la raíz
cuadrada de 16 esto es igual a
-6 y bueno la raíz principal de 16 es 4
por este menos me va a quedar menos
cuatro menos cuatro es igual a de menos
seis y si las sumamos seis de ambos
lados de esta ecuación puede obtener que
2 es igual a de y está de lujo ya tengo
aquí el valor de de que estoy buscando
así que observa si sustituye es el valor
de the x 2 justo aquí y pones aquí el
valor de 2 entonces esta ecuación de
aquí tiene como solución x igual a menos
3 por lo tanto será la solución de esta
ecuación de rosa que tenemos aquí y
también será solución de esta ecuación
de amarillo que tenemos aquí pero ojo no
va a ser solución de la ecuación
original por lo tanto será una solución
extraña y es más podemos verificarlo si
te vale 2 entonces esto va a valer 2 y
cuando x vale menos tres entonces me va
a quedar de este lado menos nueve más 25
esto va a ser 16 y de este otro lado me
va a quedar 2 menos 626 es lo mismo que
menos 4 y bueno ya puedes ver que la
raíz cuadrada de 16 la raíz cuadrada
positiva no va a ser igual a menos 4 y
por lo tanto está diciendo que el valor
de de igualados cumple que cuando x vale
menos 3 nos encontremos con una solución
extraña para esta ecuación original
aunque bueno sea solución para la
ecuación de amarillo